[Music]
good morning
let me show you something wait
it's like pretty early in the morning
so why would anyone want to move to
japan it probably starts with anime
you just randomly stumble across one of
those weird asian cartoons
you give it a try because you really
have nothing better to do right now
suddenly you're hooked you watch after
show after show
especially that one about pirates you
find the japanese culture a bit weird at
first but before you know it
you love it though you're not entirely
sure how to feel about that
samurai ramen sakura onsen everything
looks so
damn aesthetic and you wonder how you
would look like in one of those kimonos
or whatever they're called
you rightfully get obsessed with all
that stuff and you find more people
telling you just
how awesome it was in japan and wow
there seems to be a lot more people into
this than you originally thought
you decide it's time to learn japanese
you sit down
study for a week and then give up
because yeah you love anime but you also
have a life and a job and even though
you really tried you just keep confusing
katakana and hiragana
and there's a ton of particles and
you're not entirely sure how to use them
all
and even though kanji look really cool
you google and find out that you
probably need to learn at least a
thousand of these
before you can even get close to reading
a manga whatever and by the way what the
hell
is this but you really want to make a
few japanese friends to talk to you
back to anime this time you get
absolutely obsessed with food
so japanese sushi soba tofu udon mizo
there is a lot of food you tried at your
local japanese restaurant and it tastes
fantastic but you wonder what it would
be like to have that ramen in a small
shop in one of those steamy side streets
in tokyo
is this stuff really like in the anime
in case you watch the movie this
is the restaurant from your name
and then there are the great landscapes
the temples the mountains the rice
fields the cities
everything looks so damn peaceful and
you just kind of want to see and
feel that for yourself you wonder if it
all really looks like that
watch the sakura blossoms go to a
festival hear the ring of a high school
bell
could this be your big adventure
only one way to find out but first we
have to get
[Music]
that alarming new covet mutation seen in
the uk japan has decided to expand the
entry of almost considering declaring a
state of emergency
i literally just uh booked my flight i
booked
my accommodation over test for like 200
bucks and
right now an hour later the japanese
government
has probably decided to close the
borders
starting with the 28th of december my
flight was scheduled for the 29th which
means
that i won't be able to fly so yeah this
sucks
next update right now it just looks like
japan won't
basically allow new visas so i might go
because i already have my visa but i
really don't know how to feel
i just hope i'm just so nervous excited
so i'm gonna get tested now i'm gonna
fly tomorrow
i hope everything works out later i'm
gonna call the embassy then i'm gonna
finish packing and then hopefully gonna
gonna fly tomorrow
gonna get my nose swapped now
[Music]
i actually made it to the airport
through security i guess now we got to
see if everything worked
first flight is to frankfurt and from
there
to tokyo
[Music]
okay so i've actually made it to
frankfurt i already got my
ticket and now i'm gonna go to the gate
and hope that everything goes well
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so i made it into japan as you can see
this is the very nice bathroom
and then my bedroom there's the bed
there's a window there
is a desk right here so that's basically
uh
the room a place that's strategically
incredibly smart
on my back
[Music]
rainy days in tokyo like ah
i'm really excited to visit a lot of
places do a lot of things not starting
to snow
oh my god
you